normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government this
is a tweet that's been uh reposted by
Libby Emmons it is of Michael rapor A
man who utterly despises Donald Trump
and still to this day despises Donald
Trump but uh this comedian this man who
hates Donald Trump I'll say it again has
a message for all of you y'all ready to
hear it if it comes down to Pig dick
Donald
Trump and smoking Joe
Biden I'm
sorry I am
sorry voting for pig dick Donald Trump
is on the table oh I'm
sorry I'm I'll still call slob
dick Donald Trump Pig dick Donald Trump
and all
that but we need to get this whole
situation under control and you
know what that situation is he's talking
about he's talking about far leftists
that are storming uh uh trying to storm
the DNC they're storming into I think a
university a few hours ago he's talking
about the far-left protesters in New
York City cheering on Hamas and I just
think it's absolutely
hilarious that this guy who hates Donald
Trump and I'm not going to speak to him
as what he as to what he said about
January 6 but the fact that so many
people are moving in this direction
despite screaming that Donald Trump is a
fascist hitlerian psychopath who tried
to overthrow the US government they
genuinely claimed they claimed that
Donald Trump was a threat to this
country but then Israel got threatened
and now all of a sudden it's like oh I
don't care about this country I'll vote
for Donald Trump yeah as long as we get
what we want over there huh kind of
shows what his priorities are but I'm
just heartbroken I'm heartbroken because
this guy was in True Romance which is
one of my favorite movies ever and he's
now just like a you know a character of
himself so outside outside of that I'll
just say this I'm not gonna I don't want
to rag on Rapa or um he's allowed to
hate TR Donald Trump that's totally fine
I I I don't know what he said about
January 6 I'd be willing to bet he had a
lot of crazy things uh uh crit critical
things of trump fine if he's coming out
now and saying hey man I'm starting to
realize these far- LEF this are crazy
and this is what it took I'll take what
I can get I'm not going to I'm not going
to push him away anybody who comes to me
and says I didn't realize the far left
wanted to kill you know uh uh let's just
be very careful supported Hamas that to
a great proportion supported Hamas and
we're posting images of paragliders
coming into is very delicate here
they didn't know that so be it I will
say shake my hand buddy we're going to
vote for Donald Trump together right
well look that's fair uh but I just
don't I don't look at rapid port and his
unhinged Behavior over the past four
years and go like like this is an ally
in any former fashion yeah he may vote
for Trump he might but he's still he's
just as crazy as the people that are
Marching for Hamas I but but look he can
say whatever he wants he can believe
whatever he wants but if we truly
believe and you you probably don't but
I'm saying for me that Donald Trump is
our best path forward in 2024 for a
variety of reasons if this guy is saying
he's going to he's goingon to help me
out with that oh I say yes here's here's
the way I was talking to Scott Horton
after the show uh great dude we had him
on culture war and I said look man if I
see Donald Trump and he's having a
snowball fight with Hillary Clinton and
he's just whipping him at her and she's
getting hit and she's about to be
knocked off her bounds into a nice snow
pile it's all good fun everybody it's
all good fun and then he runs out of
snowballs and he looks at me and he goes
Tim I need one more one more snowball
I'm going to throw him a snowball if
Michael rapor is the guy who's got I'll
be like let's go and if he throws a
snowball to Trump and then Trump whips
one last snowball hitting Hillary and
she falls backwards into the snow you
get my point I'm very nice okay we're
having a very fun familyfriendly game of
a snowball fight and Hillary falls down
and then she giggles and laughs and
everyone's happy but Trump wins that's
my point look i' I've said before you
know I'm not a trump supporter but I
don't disagree with you that he's
probably probably the best bet at
getting me any closer to what I want to
see but I just don't have any confidence
in him because of what happened during
2020 and that's the reason I don't I
don't support him um but yeah I I think
that obviously if it's if it's Gavin
Nome like I would be I would be out of
my mind not to prefer Trump over Nome
you gonna vote for him probably
not probably not well I'll put it like
this vote for I'll put it like this hold
on I'll put it like this if I'm in a
swing state which currently I am I'm in
Florida
wait are you joking isn't it a swing
state no well I mean it went very hard
for DeSantis but it's been a swing state
historically so not even for no I think
for trump it was even it was even better
okay well then I don't if my vote
doesn't matter then you know who I'm
voting for uh but if it if it's if if
there's some theoretical possibility
that my vote will actually swing things
then yeah maybe I'd consider Trump but
look I'm not look you're putting me in a
corner Tim don't make me endorse this
guy no I don't have to do this you don't
have to endorse Trump you can even
outright say he's awful but man like I
said if Donald Trump is the one who's
engaging in that snowball fight against
the The Establishment machine and the
war machine I'm like the look no new
Wars he he that dude tried so hard to
get us out of Syria I'm just like I was
saying this to Dave Smith not not the LA
yesterday but the last time I was here I
was like come on man I know the drone
strikes are bad I know the bombing in
Afghanistan was bad but he set a
timeline there were no new Wars he tried
getting our troops out of Syria if I can
take an inch from anybody back towards
pulling our troops out I will take to
you know to your point there like and
this is one of my frustrations with
Libertarians is they're always so
they're so frequently looking for Purity
and if you look like to look at the
United States government and the United
us Empire Global Empire with military
bases and 120 or something countries
around the world the idea that you
should throw
away someone that is trying to trying to
pull back on the US government trying to
actually make real Cuts because they
were unsuccessful when literally you're
going to have the most powerful
government in all of human history
working against you because that
government has incentive to stop you
from making Cuts so for for for
Libertarians to do to to say things like
oh you know that guy's total garbage
because he he there were some Wars or
there were still Wars going on or he
didn't end all the wars it's like think
about the task that you're demanding
this person do immediately or within
four years with the amount of resistance
that they're going to have to deal with
it is outside of realistic to say this
person was elected and they didn't undo
250 years of encroachment on your
Liberties and blah blah blah in four
years so we they're all bad that is
ridiculous it's a bit of a straw man of
my position though no no I'm not saying
it's I'm say I'm saying there are there
are Libertarians like that you're
absolutely right but here's the reality
he he did not try to shrink the size of
the government he did try to end some
unconstitutional illegal Wars and God
bless him for that but he also increased
the size of the federal government
significantly and he stood by during the
most catastrophic decision of any
president in my lifetime in terms of
domestic policy which was the covid
lockdowns and that's that is the like
honest to God if it if it weren't for
2020 I probably would have supported
Donald Trump I probably would have I I
think I I actually I think it's fair I I
view it this way like the libertarian
argument you've got two guys who go back
and forth whacking you with a stick and
then finally you get a guy who's like no
no no no he hit you 10 times I'm going
to hit you eight times so vote for me
and the reformist argument is just take
the eight wax instead of the 10 and then
the libertarian argument is screw you
all I'm not I'm not playing your game so
I can respect that I can my attitude is
just I think the the the best I I I
choose the reformer position of man I
know Trump is far from perfect but he
was a net positive and that's all that
matters well I I think on domestic
policy and changing the dialogue amongst
the American people He was largely a net
positive the issue is that for whatever
reason being a businessman being a
businessman myself I don't understand
why he doesn't understand fed policy
more why he doesn't understand that his
brow beating of uh I don't know if it
was pal at the time I think it was but
trying to drive down interest rates even
lower uh you know wanting to pass
trillions of dollars in stimulus
spending during the co era without votes
without roll call votes trying to evict
Massie who's the greatest Congressman of
the past decade out of power because he
wanted to have a roll call vote to have
people on record for a $3 trillion
spending bill which is something that
historically we would have never even
considered as being feasible there's
just a lot of behaviors from him that
goes counter to this narrative that he
is actually a small government guy no
demat but but that's not even that's not
even my point CU I don't disagree with
you the only thing I disagree with on is
Massie I would say Matt Gates as
especially considering the fight with uh
uh uh um with McCarthy sure but you know
Massie is pretty great I'm a big fan uh
although you know he very much supported
McCarthy we know that McCarthy behind
the scenes was sabotaging people and I
agree and that's bizarre it's insane and
brutal but it really comes down to for
me I mean typically the most important
thing is is foreign policy and my
attitude has has has long been I mean
this is just how I grow up that the
United States bickers amongst it amongst
its own people about the things we
deserve and the things we've done wrong
while everyone ignores the bombing the
humanitarian crisis the arming the the
massacres I mean and and this is this is
what this is why I mean it's kind of
crazy to think it was Obama before
Donald Trump so we get Donald Trump and
I'm like what's going on things are
actually kind of okay like what do we
have what do we have with Barack Obama
extrajudicial extrajudicial
assassinations how many weddings did he
blow up the the expansion of middle M
Middle Eastern conflict Syria look at
Libya this these outright disasters
these hospitals too blw up hospitals no
question Donald Trump did better than
Barack Obama a million ways when it
comes to foreign policy MH not perfect a
lot of bad things too so for me it's
kind of like this uh I've had friends
who are like we deserve Healthcare and
I'm like okay let's talk about after we
stop blowing up kids in Yemen and and
Pakistan aged and so when Donald Trump
comes in and he's like no new Wars
timeline for getting our troops out get
our troops out of Syria and we watch the
Deep State lie to the American people
and Trump to keep troops in Syria the
only like I'll tell you Trump should not
have fired 59 tomahawk missiles at Syria
that's the one time the Press started
praising him right or or the Moab yeah
so I look at anything else and my view
really is and I yall can disagree with
me by all means spaming the chat ones my
attitude is my priorities over uh my
view of say like covid lockdown stuff
and Donald Trump's role in it is a much
lower priority to the United States
spending American taxpayer dollars or
what I should say is extracting our
buying power in order to wage war in
foreign countries so when someone says
yeah but Trump did this Co thing I'm
like you know what I got to be honest
I'd be willing to accept Penance in in
terms of some detriment to my quality of
life if it means the US stopped doing
all of that to be fair the reality is
the inverse if the US stops doing all
that in fact there's quite a good
argument our lives would improve I agree
that's that's a great I'll take Trump
that's a really important point because
there's this there's this kind of
myth that I think that the American
people have been sold that in some way
we have benefited the the average
American has somehow benefited from the
Empire it couldn't be further from the
truth our purchasing power is declining
very rapidly all of the people that have
actually benefited from it have been the
worst corporations if not in modern era
than maybe in all of human history some
of the worst actors out there the
boeings and all these other companies
that are actually literally just
profiting by the billions based off of
uh death and destruction of innocent
people it's horrific um but there's this
there's this belief that like we have to
police the world to kind of make it safe
for the global economy people people
don't consider the fact that all of
these other nations have the same
imperative they have the same desire to
have safe shipping lanes it's there is
no there is no actual requirement that
the American government be the policeman
of the world we ought to handle Regional
security Russia and China ought to be
handling their their portions of the
Pacific to keep it safe and we ought to
be handling ours but that's not how it's
been it's been the American Empire is
expected to go and police everything and
it is absolutely bankrupting us can I
can I I just want to point something out
too based on what I just said I mean I
don't know if it's coincidental at all
that 2019 we see the best numbers of Our
Lives economically I'm talking I'm not
talking about government spending and
stuff we can absolutely criticize all
that but unemployment is weigh down wage
growth is improving people are are are
expressing this in poll
at the same time that Donald Trump is
actively working against the war machine
mhm and I'm not saying I can
definitively prove one for one that's
what it's all about but I would like to
just live in that reality so by all
means please knock me out of it prove to
me that our economy doing doing well in
this time frame and Donald Trump's
positions on rejecting Wars are totally
unrelated but I will accept it and I
will roll that dice again yeah if Donald
Trump can recreate 2018 and 2019 and and
further those missions it's just it's
there and let him let him say all the
naughty things let him say all the nasty
things and all of my like my views on on
how bad 2020 was I'm just like if the
end result is we go through a hard
period but four years later our borders
are more secure manufacturing has come
back we're no longer doing these insane
trade deals with China the American
economy has dramatically improved and
the Foreign Wars have been whittel down
the US now our allies are actually
paying their fair share as we pull our
troops back CU they shouldn't be in many
of these countries I mean that is like a
dream yeah I I don't see I don't think
that Donald Trump as a gen who can make
it all just perfectly come true right
but we had a little taste of it in his
first term and it wasn't so bad I get I
get I get the argument I totally get the
argument that here's the issue it
because I come from the Austrian
economics backdrop and because I was a
finance guy I look at this and I and I
look at the the elevated inflationary
pressure that we're dealing with with
nearing on $34 trillion in our national
debt you have all of the debt carry
that's necessary for that debt that is
that is ultimately going to really put a
damper on growth you know GDP broadly I
think that we're we're facing a very
severe recession the other thing that
people aren't really privy to is that
because of the elevated interest rate
cycle all of the long-term uh debt
instruments that the banks filled their
their books with over the past couple
years when the interest rates were at
record lows those are now upside down to
the tunes of billions and billions and
billions of dollars so you have a a
potential banking contagion simult
coinciding perfectly with a potential uh
National you know debt and Fiat crisis
and then you also have the potential for
a global recession so we're the reason I
I bring all this up is to say if you
don't have someone who's in power soon
very very soon that is actually equipped
to handle this we're in a lot of trouble
and that that's the primary reason that
I can't give any sort of real
endorsement for Donald Trump is that he
has not demonstrated a capacity to wrap
his head around the severity of the
situation that that we that approaches
us and I feel like V gets that and
that's the primary reason that if I had
my brothers V over over Trump all day
Trump ramaswami 2024 would you vote for
it probably yeah I definitely I mean
there question I'd vote for Trump ham
sandwich 2024 just because you know
obviously I would still rather a
Libertarian get in there that's that's
setting that aside because I understand
how severe the financial situation is
and because everyone I know and love
lives here and I know that their
retirement is on the line and their way
of life is on the line their Safety and
Security is ultimately on the line with
all of these potential fronts for World
War III it's super important that we get
someone in there that is both
non-interventionist but also a fiscal
Hawk we need both of those things very
very soon we cannot continue to wait for
a hero but we need we need real changes
on the on the most important that's why
it's a great argument to say support V
and when it comes to accept Trump yeah
well and and if if aake is actually
there to advise him I would have a lot
more faith in Donald Trump I I I I hope
and I beg and I pray that the very least
whatever happens V has some kind of
advisory role with the Trump
Administration if he doesn't it would be
a huge miscalculate in fact it would
demonstrate that Donald Trump hasn't
learned anything from filling his
cabinet with some of the worst warhawks
on Earth I'd still take
it I mean you're much you're much more
forgiving than me but it's not about
forgiving it's about you can options
yeah yeah yeah yeah I understand you
could say Donald Trump is bad for all
these reasons and I'll say yep and if
it's no new Wars if if dead stop in
foreign invasion is all we get that's
four years I'll take yeah like I mean I
would love to see you know the good Dr
Ron Paul run again and and I'd love to
see him win um I'd love to see anyone
that's going to make significant cuts at
the bureau you know bureaucratic level
I'd love to see cabinet level positions
totally abolished but if all I can get
is Donald Trump then it's better than
you know four more years of Biden or the
the actual problem de stuff too that's
even even getting it's a big problem
it's a real it is really it is really
tearing at the fabric of civilization
listen not not for nothing but like all
of the the people that are pro Palestine
in the US they're not pro Palestine
because they're they have an affinity
for Islam thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net